[Rires]
la tam a priori bienvenue
bienvenue dans cette nouvelle vidéo
alors aujourd'hui j'aimerais vous parler
de raymond boudon et de l'inégalité des
chances surtout à l'école raymond boudon
est un petit peu le concurrent de pierre
bourdieu et vont offrir une vision un
peu différente une interprétation
théorique différente de celle de pierre
bourdieu à l'époque où pierre bourdieu
et raymond boudon à bord de cette
question des inégalités scolaires on
constaterait de réelle inégalité
objective un fils de cadres a beaucoup
plus de chances d'atteindre l'université
qu'un fils par exemple ouvriers raymond
boudon va définir l'inégalité des
chances comme la différence de
probabilités pour des élèves d'atteindre
les plus hauts niveaux d'enseignement en
fonction de leur origine sociale pour
lui il y a deux effets qui joue et qui
empêche finalement les enfants issus des
classes et plus populaires d'arriver sur
les filières les plus valorisé
socialement les enfants issus des
familles les plus favorisés auront plus
de ressources culturelles pour aborder
les activités scolaires mais c'est la
demande en éducation des familles qui
est le principal vecteur d'inégalités
scolaires
on constate statistiquement que les
familles les plus aisées s'engage
généralement dans les études les plus
longues qui seront les plus valorisé
socialement les enfants des classes plus
populaire s'engage généralement dans des
voies d'enseignement beaucoup plus
courte ce constat est d'autant plus vrai
lorsque les résultats de l'élève sont
médiocres des familles aisées qui ont
des enfants avec des résultats scolaires
médiocres continue à pousser ses enfants
dans les filières les plus difficiles et
les plus longues tandis qu'un enfant
d'un milieu moins favorisés il ya des
résultats médiocres ne sera pas pousser
de la même façon et sera réorientée vers
des filières plus court ou moins
valorisés pour raymond boudon la
question se pose surtout au point de
bifurcation qui sont les moments où il
va falloir choisir entre différentes
orientations entre différentes filières
entre différentes possibilités au niveau
scolaire pour comprendre ce phénomène
raymond boudon nous propose de réfléchir
à la rationalité qui est celle des
différentes familles comment les
familles envisage-t-elle les choses
quels sont les calculs et les
raisonnements qu'elle met en place pour
prendre leur décision
les différentes familles vont évaluer à
la fois les bénéfices que pourront
rapporter chaque étude chaque type
d'étude
elles vont prendre en compte les coûts
que cela représente que ce soit en
termes financiers ou par exemple en
termes de déplacements ou
d'investissement en temps et elles vont
aussi prendre en compte le risque le
risque d'échec évidemment inhérents à
chaque entreprise scolaire les familles
les plus favorisés vont vouloir
rentabiliser l'effort scolaire avec des
diplômes assez élevé qui permettront de
garantir un statut social important
équivalent finalement à celui des
parents il faut entreprendre des études
plus longues pour arriver si pas au même
statut social que les parents dépassés
finalement leur statut social et le coût
que peut représenter ce type d'étude
n'est pas un obstacle étant donné que
ces familles là ont justement beaucoup
de ressources pour pouvoir assumer c'est
dans les familles moins favorisées étant
donné que les parents ont généralement
un niveau de diplôme moins important la
filière courte peut déjà être très
rentable puisqu'elle permettra si pas de
conserver le même statut social pour la
génération suivante mais dépassé ce
statut social puisque on pouvait avoir
des familles qui n'ont aucun diplôme et
donc obtenir un diplôme même dans une
filière plus courtes ou moins valorisé
c'est déjà un diplôme et c'est déjà une
progression
quant au coût est bien les études des
plus longues horaire réel coup parce
qu'en terme de déplacements en termes de
minerval par exemple de dépenses qui va
falloir assumer par rapport aux filiales
et plus longues ces familles n'ont pas
les ressources suffisantes et là où se
distinguent finalement clairement
raymond boudon et pierre bourdieu c'est
sur ce point de demande d'éducation
raymond boudon précise même ceux ci la
demande d'éducation est une cause
nettement plus importante de l'inégalité
des chances que l'héritage culturel pour
préparer cette petite leçon je me suis
principalement basées sur ce petit
bouquin qui est un bouquin de
méthodologie écrit par raymond boudon
lui-même et renault filleul dans lequel
ils résument en quelques pages assez
bien finalement cette théorie et qui
reste relativement accessible pour des
élèves de 6e secondaire
voilà cette vidéo est terminée je vous
remercie et à très bientôt
[Musique]
on